Wayne Brady is about to see his daughter
make her daytime debut and only et was
there to see her on this set I think I
feel like a giddy stage dad it makes me
want to cry
i I've had a couple near tear moments
proud pop was an understatement
Wayne's little girl Miley is following
in his acting footsteps the 15 year olds
getting her big break guest starring on
the bold and the beautiful so what's his
sage advice to his only child has to be
don't aim to be famous just get really
good and I think that's really important
nowadays in the world of social media
preach here we are on in the back seat
of the car with the best day in the
world these two have a tight bond and
love to perform together
I just love Talent so when that Talent
happens to be in your house so I had to
tape it and the next thing I know you
know we're talking about it and then
we're on bold and beautiful so it's
pretty cool but will they ever work
together professionally he wants me to
dress up as him for Halloween
stop stop put my business out one day
for the for the two of us to be on stage
together or on camera I think that's the
dream is if we could be on Broadway
together
[Music]